[Applause]
thank you all very much you might be
wondering amid all the excitement and
all the things we've been talking about
over this weekend uh Trump and the
border and China and the economy
suddenly there's this talk about Jihad
who let this guy in from
2004 uh how did this come to be an issue
nowadays when nobody's thinking about it
so I wanted to alert you to the fact
that unfortunately it has not gone away
and we are in the paradoxical position
now of having more Jihad more open about
being Jihad all around the world today
and less discussion of what it is and
why this is all happening than ever and
so even though there is so much more of
it nobody seems to be aware or
interested in that fact except the
jihadis who were still at it and so for
example I have uh this was just November
8th so that was a couple of weeks ago a
shikh from Iraq uh yusf an Neri he spoke
on Russia Today
television and he said our war in
Palestine is not just a Palestinian Ian
Zionist War it is a global
war now that seems to me to be a
perfectly clear statement because the
war in Israel is indeed a global war as
the only reason why there has never been
peace the only reason why every
negotiated settlement fails is because
of the Jihad principle that any land
that has ever belonged to Islam has ever
been governed by Islamic law belongs to
Islam
forever the Quran says drive them out
from where they drove you out and so if
the land was ruled by Islam and it is no
longer then the Muslims have a
responsibility before Allah as strong as
the Ten Commandments for Jews and
Christians to drive out those who now
govern the land so the war against
Israel is a classic Jihad and that's
really all that it is paradoxically if
you read the statements out of Hamas
Palestinian Islamic Jihad his balah even
the Palestinian Authority which is
reputed to be moderate every last one of
them frames the conflict in terms of
jihad and Islam and then if you read the
state department and the European Union
and the United Nations not a one of them
ever in a single document considers for
a second the implication of the fact
that this is an Islamic Jihad and so
when this guy says this is not a local
conflict this is a global war what he
means is this is part of the Jihad that
is also being waged in every other place
around the world and yet this is the one
statement this simple statement that the
Palestinian Zionist War as he called it
is a global war that would make no sense
to anyone in the state department today
they don't have any intellectual
apparatus to understand what that
statement even means or to grasp its
implications because they are
dogmatically committed to the idea that
Islam is peaceful that Jihad is this
interior spiritual struggle and that
consequently if there is rhetoric about
Jihad from for example the Palestinian
Authority or Hamas or whoever that then
that's just a rhetorical screen for the
real problem which is geographical or
economic or some combination of both
such that if the Israelis just give back
enough land and allow for a Palestinian
State then there will be peace and this
conflict has nothing whatsoever to do
with the conflict in Afghanistan or the
conflict in India with Kashmir between
India and Pakistan or the genocide of
Christians in Nigeria or any of the
other jihads around the
world but this guy and his colleagues
they understand very well what the
implications are of the fact that the
war in Israel is just one theater of a
World War that is the Islamic Jihad to
fight until religion is all for Allah as
the Quran says so the same Sheik he said
for us it is all the same whether Trump
Harris or anyone else wins the elections
this was actually right after the
election but that's what he said there's
no difference between the Republicans
and the Democrats when it comes to
foreign policy they are all the same the
only difference is that Trump is not a
hypocrite Trump is a manifest
Infidel now what does that mean see
these statements are all very important
and they're full of
implications he's saying Harris was a
hypocrite what's a hypocrite that you
say one thing but you really believe
something different this is a very
important category in Islam if you read
the Quran it's full of castigations of
the Hypocrites people who say they're on
your side but they're not really this is
a very important theological concept
it's not tangential or
incidental and what he's saying is is
that the left pretends to be on our side
but they're not Trump he's obviously not
on our side he's a manifest Infidel and
notice the Infidel term that he's
putting this once again in the language
of a religious conflict his problem with
Trump is that Trump is not a
Muslim his problem with Harris is that
she pretends to be friendly on his side
but she's not really she doesn't really
mean it now this is in in fact a
reflection of the larger leftist Islamic
Alliance which I've discussed many times
in this same venue over the years some
of you may recall that we've discussed
how the left loves Islam because when
you're talking about socialist
internationalists they are
authoritarian and they hate nation
states because obviously if you've got
an internationalist program then you
want to go to war against the world's
foremost nation state which is the
United States so say if you got
socialist internationalist sabots and
one of them becomes president of the
United States one thing he might do
would be erase the southern border and
let in millions of people and so then
you dilute the national character you
destroy the national culture and you set
up a voting base for yourself forever
with all the welfare cases that you've
brought in and you destroy the world's
foremost Nation state in the service of
your internationalist agenda the
internationalist agenda is authoritarian
they want to establish not a global
democracy as they constantly speak about
but actually they the Biden regime as we
saw many times made many moves against
the freedom of speech they tried to set
up the disinformation governance board
and they got shot down but they worked
with the social media Giants to stifle
dissent and de platform to centers they
did a number of other things to show
that they are no enemy no friends of a
free
Society in Islam there is a Hadith a
report about Muhammad's words where he
says that obey your ruler even if he is
an Ethiopian with a head like a
raisin now people quote that to say look
what a racist Muhammad was and that's a
perfectly reasonable point but I think
the more important point is that he's an
authoritarian he's saying obey the ruler
no matter what that's music to the
left's
ears because they want to inculcate that
kind of blind obedience to their agenda
and the criminalization of dissent
that's why they had trumped up so to
speak all those charges against the
president-elect so you have this
alliance between the left and Islam the
left has been encouraging Islam in the
west particularly in Europe because they
want to inculcate that kind of obedience
to the authority and the
internationalism of Islam Islam says
that your obedience Your Allegiance to
the global umah trumps all other
allegiances overrides your National
Allegiance your ethnic Allegiance
anything
else and so the left loves Islam at the
same time Islam is not so happy with the
alliance it'll use it but they don't
like the the Embrace of sexual deviant
Madness delusion men thinking they're
women and so it's a shaky Alliance and
so he says Harris is a hypocrite Trump
is
not then he says the US dollar and the
American economy must be
destroyed now you might wonder why would
an Iraqi Sheik who is talking about
Israel say the US dollar in the American
economy must be destroyed because here
once again he is thinking of this as a
Global struggle not as a local one and
yet every Authority every analyst who is
making policy in Washington thinks of
the Israel Palestinian conflict as a
local struggle with no International
implications Beyond Middle East
relations they don't even stop to think
wait a minute Iran hates Israel but why
does Iran hate Israel Israel has no
territorial claims over Iran Israel
never threatened Iran Israel has no
economic uh competition with Iran What
on earth makes Iran hate Israel it's
Islamic Jihad that's the only reason if
Islam if Iran were not an Islamic
Republic then Iran and Israel could be
friends as they were in the time of the
Sha but because Islam teaches this drive
them out from where they drove you out
which is Quran and thus there is no
higher authority then Iran has Israel as
its former most
enemy and so these things go completely
by the foreign policy
establishment and yet these things are
the key to the conflict now there's
another Imam I wanted to quote for you
and that is TK Alan who is at the Muslim
American society Staten Island Center in
New York City and on October 25th he
preached a Friday sermon and he was
talking about Jihad and and he was
saying that you don't have to wage armed
Jihad but remember that there are
immense blessings if you wish to if you
want to and if you will take the
opportunity when it comes to you to do
so and he said you were living safely
today here in America who is to say that
your situation will not change in the
next 10 years that you will not be
living in a circumstance or situation
where Jihad will apply to you and think
about what we've seen over the last few
years that we've known that the left
controls the college campuses for
decades and David and many others have
spoken out against this raised awareness
about it but now we're seeing it go to a
new level with the encampments and with
the increasing threats against Jewish
and pro-israel students on
campuses and now it's gone to an even
more threatening and dangerous level we
have open support for Hamas expressed
freely on college campuses remember that
Hamas is still a designated terrorist
group by the US state department we have
at Concordia University in Canada just
yesterday we had people doing the Hitler
salute and calling for a final
solution and so the real problem here is
that the university administrators don't
really do anything about this except for
a few token gestures here and there
because of course they're largely
sympathetic to this point of
view and because they're
afraid and so we're already
seeing the step that is the step right
before active
violence on college campuses and
elsewhere we saw promas mob marched
through a Jewish neighborhood in
Brooklyn just the other day this also
it's a very clear threat why can't they
March anywhere else they want to
frighten the people they want to do
actually what here again what the Quran
says strike Terror in the enemies of
Allah how how better to strike Terror
than to be marching through you know
you're you're you're in your house and
having a peaceful evening and there are
people outside screaming for your head
and I mean that quite literally because
they chant Kar Kar oh Jews the army of
Muhammad will return which is a
reference to the kibar Oasis in Northern
Arabia where Muhammad carried out a
surprise attack and a massacre of the
Jews According to Islamic tradition and
so when they say Kar kyar yahood people
don't understand they think oh they're
saying some Arabic thing and uh it's
it's an ancient chant yeah sure it's
those things but kibar means we're going
to come and Massacre
you and so here again the lack of
knowledge about what we are dealing with
is still hamstringing our ability to
deal with it t Alam also said Alan the
prophet said that Allah will spread this
matter of Islam to all the corners of
the earth and Allah La will not leave a
single house except for this religion
will enter it
through honoring those who deserve honor
through Islam or humiliating those who
deserve humiliation through disbelief so
Allah made this promise that this
religion will reign supreme over all
religions this guy is speaking in Staten
Island do you think there's any
possibility that he might be responsible
for some civil Strife that we could very
well see in Staten Island or its
environs in the near
future and meanwhile the UK and Spain
and Germany and the Netherlands and
Denmark and Sweden and other countries
in the west have all recently in ins
imposed criminal proceedings uh
initiated sorry criminal
proceedings against people who
criticized
Islam because they say that it it harms
social cohesion now the problem with
that is that you can say well those
people they were all ha ful they were
all uh bigoted and uh they were going
off half coocked and saying crazy things
well that's not always the case
unfortunately the situation that we have
is 20 years of indoctrination into the
idea that any criticism of Islam is
islamophobic and bigoted and
consequently should be shut
down so for example I had this guy write
me the other
day he was a professor in Warren
Michigan he's 82 years old and he told
me his story that he's kind of a local
historian there in Warren Michigan and
he writes about what's happened what
what what the history of the city is but
he also he had been in the military he
had studied Islam and so he wrote some
things on his Facebook 10 years
ago that were critical of Islam and so
recently the mayor of Warren Michigan
Lori Stone she appointed him this kindly
old man to the city's historic
commission it's what could be more
harmless and innocuous than being on the
historic Commission in Warren Michigan
who could possibly object well somebody
dug up his Facebook quotes from 10 years
ago that were critical of Islam and
initiated a recall petition to take
mayor Lorie Stone out of office because
she had appointed this man to the
historic
commission and I could stand here and
give you story after Story of local
officials all over the United States who
have been forced to resign forced to
apologize because they said things that
were absolutely
true about Islam and
Jihad and they were made to leave their
positions Under Pressure because
anything remotely negative regarding
Islam is now forbidden this is the land
of the free and the home of the brave
and we have the freedom of speech but
when it comes down to practice there are
many restrictions on it and one of the
foremost we've been talking about cancel
culture here this weekend and how it's
receding and that's all to the good but
one of the first victims of cancel
culture were the people who were talking
honestly about what Islam and Jihad were
all about and that's been a total
victory for the
councellors they have been able to carry
the day such that now people have
internalized the idea that if you speak
critically about Islam then you have
done something that is very very far out
of bounds
and you can no longer be in polite
company and this prevails among the
right as well as the left I was speaking
uh out in California and there was a
candidate this was last summer there was
a local candidate speaking before me and
he spoke to the crowd about how he had
gone to Culver City to the King Fahad
mosque which is a Saudi mosque that has
numerous ties to ter terrorists and he
didn't say anything like that he was
just saying it's very important that we
make an Outreach to the Muslim
Community and I was the first Republican
candidate to go speak at the king fad
mosque and I think you know this is a
very difficult
situation because of course these people
are American citizens and voters and
there are many people there who have
nothing to do with Jihad will never wage
Jihad and have no interest in Jihad and
consequently it's perfectly reasonable
for him to want to go there at the same
time if you bring up what the King Fahad
mosque's P has past has been and if you
bring up the difficulties that may be
involved in not wanting to challenge
that because you don't want to offend
this possible source of
Voters well then you see it becomes very
difficult
territory and I think all too many on
the right as well as the left have been
altogether too willing to think well we
can just embrace the moderates and
everything will be okay because the
moderates after all are the vast
majority well see here again it's very
important to have a precise
understanding of what we're dealing
with there are many Muslims and indeed
the majority who are never going to blow
anything up and that's very great but
when you're talking about Islamic
teaching there's no version of the Quran
there's no form of Islam that does not
teach Warfare against unbelievers and
the necessity to as I said this is from
the Quran 8:39 fight until religion is
all for Allah now that doesn't mean
every Muslim is going to do it but it
does mean that it is present within
Muslim communities that you have some
who are working toward
this and they are going to be working in
and among those who are not doing these
things and we need to have a steady and
sober regard for the reality of the
situation but right now that has been
completely
obscured back in 2011 the Obama
Administration instituted what it called
the countering violent extremism program
and that very carefully removed all
mention of Islam and Jihad from counter
territory
training so that ever since then the
first Trump Administration did not
correct this ever since then there has
been no branch of the US government no
US government agency nothing in the US
government that is studying Islam and
Jihad in order to understand what our
foes are all about now is that
wise isn't the first rule of warfare to
know your
enemy and yet the whole problem has been
obscured by people saying well we'll
offend our Muslim allies we will offend
the moderates we'll tell you you know
let's talk about moderates there are
about a billion and a half Muslims in
the world and 9/11 happened and many
other Jihad attacks have happened since
then most notoriously recently October
7th happened where have you seen major
Muslim organizations saying this is
terrible we reject it and we're fighting
against it where have you seen marches
demon ations you see a person here a
person there
individuals who have very little
following in the actual Islamic
communities and yet it's tempting and
unfortunately all too many of us have
fallen prey to the temptation to put all
our hope that these people are going to
turn things around well you can't turn
around what's in the perfect book that
was given from Paradise to Muhammad
through the angel Gabriel what it says
goes and unfortunately there are still
Muslims who are working toward that in
the United States so I hope in
conclusion and it is a hope uh that the
incoming Trump Administration will take
a realistic look at this problem which
has been lacking in Washington since
2011 when Obama in instituted the cve
program and incidentally think about
that that the before that we had the war
on terror the war on terror is long over
and the war on terror didn't have
anything to do with Islam either but it
was closely associated in the popular
mind the countering violent extremism
was an explicit attempt to disassociate
Islam from terrorism but what's a
violent
extremist can you point one out to me I
know you can point at me
um but the fact is it's a very it's a
it's a nothing term it doesn't mean
anything what's a violent extremist it's
whatever you want it to be and that's
the point who did the Biden
Administration make violent
extremists yeah and you think I'm
kidding you know they sent people they
sent counter Terror people into Catholic
churches to look for
pro-lifers they they they started
terrorism investigations on angry
parents protesting against critical race
Theory at Schoolboard meetings can count
ing violent extremism is a terrific
vehicle for authoritarians because you
can turn it against anybody who you want
to
eliminate in pursuit of your
authoritarian
agenda and so consequently it's
imperative I think for the Trump
Administration to revisit this to end
the cve program once and for all to
speak realistically about Islam and
Jihad and that means a a
comprehensive realist
approach that takes into account the
fact that there are many many Muslims at
different stages of fervor and knowledge
in their faith and so this is not
demonizing an entire population or any
of the rhetoric that the left has so
successfully put over on us over the
last 20 years but rather we have to deal
with the fact that these Islamic
teachings are endless Wellsprings of
recruitment for
terrorism and that's not going to change
particularly if we just keep ignoring it
and pretending that it's not
so and so the state of jihad today in
2024 is that it is more upon us than
ever and we're not paying any attention
to that fact but we have hope because we
do have an Administration that will be
full of people who are uh courageous in
uh clinging to reality saying men are
men and women or women and one can't
become the other and so on and so I hope
also that that realism will carry over
to this all important field and that we
will see a better approach in the coming
four years thank you very
[Applause]
much we actually have time we have time
for two questions before I introduce our
last speaker before lunch so I'm going
to go Phillip and then Mark I'm sorry
they had their hands up before you two
I'm sorry but we'll go with these two so
Phil and then Mark's next sure simple
question um the news reported that the
Muslims in Michigan voted for Trump
versus um Calo why yeah you know they
did because Trump said he was not going
to get involved in wars and that he
would wanted uh Netanyahu to end the war
before January 20th and so the Muslims
in Michigan were so angry with Biden and
Harris for their ostensible support of
Israel and I say ostensible because of
course we know this war wouldn't be
happening if it weren't for Biden and
Harris they are funding Hamas and his
Bala to wage war against Israel they say
they're allied with Israel but then he
sent1 billion to uh Iran and a billion
to Gaza so we're funding both sides it's
insane the Muslims in Michigan were very
angry with it quite rightly and they
said they would vote for Trump and so
apparently many of them did then now I
see that they're very angry and they say
all these pro-israel appointees in the
Trump cabinet it's been a baon switch he
fooled us he lied to us now that of
course we know is not the case Trump was
the most pro-israel president in the
history of modern Israel when he was
president before and he made no no
secret of his support for Israel so
there was no deception there was no bait
and switch it seems as if they were
hoping that they could manipulate him
based on his determination to make peace
because peace if you call for a
ceasefire now for example without Return
of the hostages then Hamas and his Bala
survive if the war goes on they will
both likely collapse so they want the
peace now and they're hoping Trump will
give it to them without the victory of
Israel that's unlikely last question do
you see any hope for Western Europe or
is it going to be one Sharia State uh I
think that's there's both actually that
there will be Sharia in Western Europe
certainly but there will also be areas
where there's there are pockets of
resistance and a lot of conflict a lot
of war in Europe coming unfortunately I
don't see any way around that now they
could have stopped this as Mike was
saying they could have stopped this 20
years ago they could have stopped it
they could have not started it in 1973
when first started when the Arab League
made agreements with the European
commission and the European commission
was given cheap oil in exchange for
unrestricted Arab immigration without
assimilation that's all that these are
this is not a conspiracy theory you read
b or Arabia you'll see all the documents
and they they brought this on themselves
and so now I don't know how they're
going to get out of it without without
armed
struggle thank you